so a couple of days ago
activision blizzard on
activisionblizzard.com
posted about king's diversity space tool
um
they've since had to add a lengthy
editor's note and they've also removed
every single image from this blog post
based on
discussion online conversation online as
they call it um so
i don't know that i have that much to
say about this i just wanted to like
highlight it for anybody who missed it
basically king if you don't know is um
probably best known for
candy crush they are one of the
companies owned by activision blizzard
and they posted a tool for how to make
more diverse characters um
the reaction has been super negative
because it comes across uh at least this
is what i'm seeing most people say
as though they are like treating certain
marginalized groups as just sort of
weird like ranks it just
very much dehumanized the whole idea so
let's read the original
uh thing obviously they've emitted the
images and then i'll come back to the
editor's note uh this is published on
may 12th so
it says
we want to see ourselves represented in
games we want the barriers to access
lowered we want games to be a welcoming
environment for all just look at the
2019 international game developers
association igda developer satisfaction
survey which asked developers what they
considered to be the most important
factor in the growth of the gaming
industry
should say games industry it's like a
pet peeve the gaming industry is casinos
um the most common response more
diversity in content it's not even a
question anymore
that could mean a lot of things in any
case however the question does remain
the question that does remain is this
how do we convert this feedback from the
collective desire into tangible reality
as expected the people at king are
already thinking a few moves ahead it's
a lovely thing to write about yourself
in 2016 king began developing a method
for guarding against unconscious bias
and exclusion when it came to the
creation of their games and characters
at the time this this idea existed as a
tangible philosophy but the potential
was obvious
that doesn't sound so bad we all have uh
unconscious biases
towards pretty much everything um and
it's something you kind of have to check
yourself on
but they
don't think they did a great job uh
enter the mit game lab alongside king
the mit techs helped turn a mission
statement into tangible software that
would create and monitor guidelines for
character conception and creation
looking into all the ways basic elements
such as gender body type roles heroes
and villains
and even such granular factors such as
pose or body movement can suggest
powerful things about a character one
way or another according to king
globalization project manager jacqueline
chamatas once mit handed over the basic
software
and i believe mit are the ones that have
the
there is like an unconscious racism tool
that they built um
i'm not positive if it's mit where you
can take a test online and it will tell
you
which way your uh bias leans um
it's
yeah they made a whole bunch of tools
that like
surround that basically it's like you
play an online game and it tells you
what your biases are that you might not
be aware of
uh so it says the team at king
spent the last few years honing and
developing it mostly as a volunteer
effort people were spending their off
hours working on the tools simply
because they believed in its potential
so much
an important principle for us at king is
all the players is that all players
should feel welcomed says shimadas the
intention is to inspire game teams not
just at king but throughout the
activision blizzard king network to
think outside the box and challenge
preconceived notions around how
characters should look and act
as a result hopefully we will create
more characters to break the mould and
better represent women non-binaries and
other underrepresented minorities in the
industry
how it works i am going to read this
whole thing so i don't know skip ahead a
couple minutes if you just want to see
the images but i just wanted to try to
give you all the information
how it works
the idea of a tool to make up characters
more diverse and inclusive may seem a
little hard to wrap your head around in
practice it has to be more than just say
a pop-up reminder between 2017 and 2021
nearly 80 of the highest selling games
in the world featured white male
protagonists according to a study
conducted by diamond lobby it needs to
become a part of the incubation process
from the start back into the pipeline as
an unmissable and and consistent step
which is exactly what this tool was
designed to be
the diversity space tool is a
measurement device god sounds so
robotic
to help identify how diverse a set of
character traits are
and in turn how diverse that character
and casts are when compared to the norm
how on earth do you quantify that
um once it establishes a baseline for
typical character traits which is done
by create by the creative team working
closely with dni experts that's
interesting because you would think the
creative team who have identified things
as typical would also have bias in that
i wonder if there's a way that they
could put data into it to find out what
typical means or like what the average
is in terms of traits that would be hard
i don't know that a robot can even do
that um it can then weigh the new
character designs against it to measure
their diversity
something very uncomfortable about this
during this process the tool can also
uncover unconscious bias such as why
certain traits are seen as male versus
female or why characters from certain
ethnic backgrounds are given similar
personalities or behaviors
um
this is a thing that i do find
interesting um character traits being
seen as male versus female there are
definitely some unhealthy like biases
where that stuff is concerned but i had
this conversation with somebody on
twitch recently
who was like
they gave me a compliment they actually
said i like i like you as a female
twitch streamer because you just wear a
t-shirt and you're not wearing a ton of
makeup like i don't understand why girls
have to dress this way and wear cat ears
and my response was just
can we just let women be women
i feel like there was this this thing
where
sometimes women are only allowed in
male-dominated spaces if they also act
like men and i think some of these tools
can kind of lean towards that too where
it's like
deciding that women should be less
feminine and that's something about
appearing to be feminine or having
cleavage or even like in some cases the
sexy female video game character trope
um
can be seen as a negative because it's
feminine
i don't know it's a weird thing that
that i don't really know how to reckon
with like i feel like
i'm being told that women being busty or
curvaceous or wearing certain kinds of
clothing
is unrealistic and doesn't happen in the
real world even though it totally does
or that should be frowned upon or is
only for the male gaze it's just it's
just confusing there's a lot going on
there i'm like why sometimes i think
that
women should just be allowed to be
feminine and that's okay but maybe
that's just me i don't know
um in this effort
the diversity space tool can clearly
delineate between token characters and
true representation the tool identifies
what stereotypical characters in
different genres look like which are not
always the most conducive or
representative of diversity
it helps identify those stereotypes
while also helping creatives look closer
at their designs so they can dissect
their own assumptions and presets i also
like wonder what this would do to
writers auto art teams
it's not negative like inherently
um
it just seems like again such a robotic
way to look at this but
uh it literally is i guess that's
literally what the tool is for
it also helps identify opportunities for
one of those character narratives to
ensure that we are not only creating
diverse characters in appearance alone i
love that
by starting at the character conception
phase the tool allows king and others to
ask these important questions at the
earliest possible moment to promote more
thoughtful creative choices from the
ground up which in turn leads to games
that are more representative of their
player base sharing and caring over the
past few months king has led developer
teams at activision and blizzard beta
test the diversity space tool
and the results have been immediate and
enthusiastic that's good
the plan is to further test the tool
internally for preliminary feedback
across activision blizzard starting this
summer we strongly believe in the tools
potential to change the gaming landscape
beyond gaming while the diversity space
tool was designed for use in game
character conception chamatus also sees
it as having broader application across
entertainment and media platforms
i wonder if everybody using the same
tool would result in
things also
becoming typical
like the diversity becoming typical
i don't know i am interested in this the
the way they're describing this like it
makes my brain go huh how did the
statistics work
um the traits and measures are
applicable to wider entertainment
verticals including tv film and
literature the only change required if
using these verticals would be the
baseline traits which would need to be
calibrated to be relevant to the genre
and universe each character exists in
chimadis i hope i'm pronouncing her name
correctly
admits that the application is still
evolving and in fact is designed to
continuously evolve as norms shift
now it sounded like scary ai and
platforms change in the end you get out
of what you put into it and what you
choose to take from it like anything
this is simply a tool that provides
insight says chamatas it's up to the
teams to create the characters and games
to apply them
some things about this that i find
unsettling but it's not wholly
unreasonable um not this part at least
um
don't love it don't don't
outrageously hate it so for the editor's
note
this went up uh on
may 13. there has been a conversation
online regarding the diversity space
tool particularly concerning its intent
and our commitment to diversity we've
edited this blog post to clarify that
this is prototype that this prototype is
not being used in active game
development we would like to add the
following comment for additional context
started in 2016 the diversity space tool
currently in beta was designed as an
optional supplement to the hard work and
focus our teams already place on telling
divorce stories with diverse characters
but decisions regarding in-game content
have been and always will be driven by
development teams the tool was developed
at king and has been beta tested by
several developers across the company
all of whom have provided valuable input
the objective of using the tool is to
uncover unconscious bias again i do
think this is something that's really
interesting
because
we all have so much unconscious bias
about everything all the time like
just that's that's part of being human
um
so that part of it
i do think is interesting and i feel
like as a human
just if you want to be a better person
and you want to grow you should always
be trying to find out your own
unconscious biases and how they affect
you and how they affect the people
around you that is interesting
um in itself
especially like for people creating
characters they don't they don't argue
against that
by identifying existing norms in
representation and acknowledging
opportunities for growth and inclusion
it is not a substitute for any other
essential effort by our teams in this
regard nor will it alter our company's
diversity hiring goals
i wonder maybe there must be some
criticism about that over the past
several years the development of the
tool was done with the support of all of
our employee de ni networks and we
collaborated with external partners to
create
an even more robust tool the tool isn't
meant to be used in isolation teams
would sit down with company de i staff
to identify existing norms and then
discuss educate consult and collaborate
on how a character's representation is
expressed beyond those norms this
process is intended to create a
conversation where our developers
assisted by the tool challenge
assumptions assess choices and find
opportunities for authentic
representation to be fostered in our
games
activision blizzard is committed to
reflecting the diversity of its millions
of players around the world through
representation and inclusion in its
games as well as its employees our
intent with this blog entry entry was to
share an in-progress piece of our
journey in this endeavor which is an
interesting choice i wonder why they
chose to share it
it was received negatively even by like
very liberal people um
i suppose they just didn't see that
coming that's gotta be my guess
uh we recognize and respect that all
people may be on their own unique point
in that journey with dee and i'm talking
weird since the diversity space tool is
not a definitive evaluation of diversity
and game content rather it is a bridge
in opening previously unspoken
conversations
into how thoughtful inclusion can happen
and thrive in games sure it is um okay
so
this is the heavily edited version so
this is according to forbes
uh this says activision blizzard heavily
edits king's diversity generator blog
removes all ranking images
um so i guess this would be one of them
let me
zoom in on this get rid of these ads so
this is an example of the diversity
space method
uh with three overwatch characters
oh this is this is confusing to even
read so is this is the middle of it like
what they consider to be normal
oh yeah so the further out you go the
more diverse you are so
age
ability wouldn't they all be significant
in ability
well maybe that's literally gameplay
body type gender identity
sexual orientation i think that means
everybody's pretty much straight
culture
and ethnicity
uh yesterday unprompted activision
blizzard released a long blog post
dedicated to showcasing a diversity
space tool made by king
in it they show how the tool can be used
to help ensure that games have diversity
and there are no blind spots from the
team in terms of underrepresented
characters while the mission sounds
noble the way the system works in
practice by assigning seemingly
arbitrary ranking numbers to different
races that's kind of the thing is that
somebody had to do that
uh genders sexualities and body types
has united both left and right leaning
gamers in condemning how terrible this
comes across which i guess is related to
the images i wish there were more of
them in here
um
so they published an addendum which
which we've read
and let's see if they have more pictures
in here
okay
so
the the images will be on the internet
forever says forbes of course and raise
a whole lot of questions like the one
that was shown of anna from overwatch
this is very blurry
but i want to take a look at it
see if we can just make that bigger
uh
here
okay
i'm trying to make sure you guys can see
it
so
anna this character is public uh
biography real name anna age 60
occupation bounty hunter base of
operations cairo egypt affiliation
overwatch everyone is fine they're
called egyptian that means she's a seven
seven out of ten diversities race arabs
seven out of ten diversities age 67 out
of 10 diversities
cognitive ability
zero
that means she has average cognitive
ability i believe is what they said
physical ability one eyed is a four
body type slim plus curvy is a zero so
again i think that means that that means
it's very common
slightly aged is a one woman is a five
heterosexual is a zero
this is a great question if anna scores
a seven out of ten for culture and race
by being an egyptian arab what exactly
is a 10 out of 10 or a 3 out of 10
literally what would make a 10 out of 10
who have you assigned that to
this is so bizarre
like getting
culture and race down to a numeric
10 out of 10 value
somebody had to do that
and other people had to agree that they
were okay with doing that
like what is a three out of ten how are
they calculated totally agree
uh if an age of 60 is also a 7 out of 10
does that say a 100 year old character
would own a 10 out of 10 or a toddler
because you don't normally see those in
fps games
true
we're ranking disabilities as well
having a missing eye gets anna a four
out of ten in physical abilities
colorblindness of one out of ten is full
paralysis is a 10 out of 10. well a
missing eye
isn't something that's unseen
in video game characters but yeah what
ranks a 10
would a 10 be
a physical
and it's in physical ability too
so
if you're ranking physical ability out
of 10
is
10 has to be something that in theory
has never been in any video game before
how
and how yeah how do you
rank certain disabilities versus other
disabilities
unless it is literally like a matter of
logging every video game character that
exists and breaking them up
yeah there's something very
uncomfortable about this
anna is a woman which gets her a 5 out
of 10. that seems weird how would trans
characters be rated here what is 10 out
of 10 in this category 10 out of 10 in
what was the category labeled
gender identity
again it would be for whatever is the
least common
how is five
woman
for gender identity
shouldn't that be zero
or maybe if they're saying male
characters are more common are they that
much more
this is very confusing
this is definitely very confusing
anna has a zero out of ten for body type
as she is slim plus kirby but another
removed image showed the muscular zarya
scored a higher body type than torbjorn
the short round dwarfish guy why
uh
yeah
very very very confusing
um and worth noting that the overwatch 2
staff say they never used activision
blizzard's diversity tool
um
multiple developers on overwatch 2 have
said the team never used the tool when
designing characters for the game which
is strange because obviously it features
overwatch characters
um
uh
came under fire i wonder if we can
get some more images from it here yeah
it seems like they've largely been
deleted which is obama
which i mean they probably should have
um but yeah apparently activision
blizzard and of which two devs have
denied its current use
uh but they did say any update it's not
being used in active development but
that makes it sound like they haven't
even tested it at all so
oh imran here
mentioned that
they removed the part of the post that
mentioned its use in overwatch 2 and
vanguard luckily i screenshot blog posts
i report about your welcome so
apparently they did say it was
originally used
um elena cole dni manager at
sledgehammer games says the tool was
tested by developer teams working call
of duty vanguard and it left a sizeable
impression
we used the diversity space tool to
figure out what more diversity looks
like across all of our characters in
both campaigns and
campaign multiplayer and live seasons
and now we're going to use the data
going forward into the next game we're
working on the overwatch 2 team at
blizzard has also had a chance to
experiment with the tool with equally
enthusiastic first impressions
apparently that's not true
dylan snyder said for what it's worth
the question about overwatch 2 was
removed mostly because we're not using
it and didn't know it existed until
yesterday
wow
so that is from dylan snyder senior game
designer at blizzard on overwatch 2.
that certainly seems like a thing he
would know about
character artist on the series melissa
kelly also commented and said i swear
own company tries so hard to slaughter
any good with will the actual devs who
make the games a belt
damn she added you know what drives our
diversity the devs we have people who
work on the game from these cultures
that's it that's literally it this
creepy chart was made for the executive
team to let us do our thing that might
track
it is very
weird very very very weird um
because you're having to rank
humans on that diversity and thus like
i don't know it's just very
uncomfortable it's just really
uncomfortable
what is a 10 out of 10 for race
you know and who decided
it's weird man i just it's weird um i
definitely wanted to catch up on it uh
shame that they've edited it um
so heavily
but uh
i guess good like maybe they're like oh
this is a bit weird i do think there's a
lot of very interesting stuff
regarding discovering your own
unconscious biases and being aware of
those and trying to actively confront
what those are
but when it comes to like ranking
characters based on their sexual
orientation
or gender identity i don't know dude
i don't know